- [Josh] Hello?
- Hello, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Josh] Oh my God,
I'm so happy to talk to you.
Oh my God.
Yo, I started my marketing--
- Hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on.
Romance a girl a
little bit here.
What's your name?
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this
was the last Monday
morning of your life?
- Hey guys, it's me, Gary.
Actually perfect.
These guys, this one and this
one just came in here and said
hey, this episode is so iconic
you should chop it up
into three episodes.
So this is not
something I want to do.
I'm blaming these two
characters right here.
And so we're gonna do
this three part episode.
Did you have the audio?
Am I mic'd?
Oh, is that what it is?
Good.
Alright, we'll
see what you think.
("Hands" by Daywlk)
- [Gary] I've been driving in
circles just so I don't have to
get out of the car.
Absolutely intrigued
by this GaryVee guy.
Hey Dana, it's GaryVee.
Thank you so much for the love.
Hope you have the
best holiday ever.
- [DRock] What did the last
girl say on the radio show?
We couldn't hear it on my...
- The last call in from Joe
was, I was driving and Gary was
making me super uncomfortable
because he was
saying stop complaining
but I love complaining
and I live my life
complaining and it just hit me.
It was amazing.
Just amazing.
She was like,
he's right and crap.
(DRock laughs)
It's easy to complain.
Complaining is the easy way out.
Negativity is the easy way out.
That's why people don't realize
what I'm doing is so hard 'cause
I do it so effortlessly.
'Cause it comes naturally to me.
It's not 'cause I'm so cool.
'Cause I got lucky from a
hardwiring standpoint and then
I was self-aware about the luck
and then I put in the work to
make myself the
best version of it.
- [DRock] Maintain it.
- What?
- [DRock] Maintaining it, right?
- 100%.
You're lucky if you're gorgeous
but if you eat like crap and
don't take care of yourself
and do drugs and drink alcohol
you'll not look gorgeous.
You're lucky if you're 6'11"
and can sprint like a gazelle
but if you don't work on your
craft then you don't work on
your outside jumper, if you
don't work on your intensity and
your endurance you
won't be an NBA player.
So, yes, I got lucky that
I can win the game of life and
entrepreneurship but I've put in
the work for the last 25 years
minimumly and maybe even longer
to be the best version
of myself at this thing.
Sissy,--
- [Elizabeth] Bro, (inaudible).
- I get it.
I mean it's so fun for you
to like because it's actually
something you listen to, right?
(laughs)
("Arizona" by Common Souls)
There was a point there
where I was like,
"Listen to the GaryVee show.
"Oh, I'm sorry, (inaudible)."
Yep.
Everybody knows.
You got it.
That's exactly, of course,
that's the whole point.
Yep, you do.
'Cause it's a brand, right?
And so, yes, I think about
brand where I think most digital
marketers think about sales.
Well, I came up with
something very smart a year ago.
We started something
called DailyVee which is my
daily vlog on YouTube.
When you heard me
earlier yelling,
"DRock," that's my
whole film world, David Rock.
DRock, he's actually sitting,
we're in an airport right now,
I'm looking at him.
He's filming me right now.
So, I'm documenting, I'm not
creating and then from that
content if I say something
clever in this interview it may
make the DailyVee and then my
team will email me and say,
"Hey, you said this quote.
"Do you want to make
that a quote card?
"A quote image on Instagram?"
I'll say yes, then they'll send
me a bunch of pictures and
I'll approve 50 at a time and
now all of a sudden I have three
Instagram posts every day
because it's my
image over a quote here.
And then they'll listen to
this whole episode and maybe it
becomes a blog post and my
writers will ask me a couple
more questions and they'll
take all my words
and create an article.
And we'll take one clip of this
for 31 seconds and it'll become
a mini-video for
Facebook and YouTube.
So what I've done is I'm
spending all of my time and none
of my time on my brand.
Yep.
So when I was a young kid I made
a lot of money selling baseball
cards and comic books and toys
and then I started working for
my dad's business and
I was making, you know,
when I was 22 to 28 I was making
$35-$55,000 a year
but I had no expenses.
I didn't go on vacations.
I didn't buy fancy things.
So I saved my money,
I save my money,
I save my money
then when, you know,
I had hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
I didn't have millions.
I had hundreds of thousands of
dollars 'cause I didn't spend
anything and then I started
making $100,000 a year and
$150,000 a year and
by the time I was 33,
34 when I had that opportunity
I'd still not bought a home.
I was still in an apartment.
I was 33 years old and I was
renting and because I was saving
cash to go on the offense and
I knew something would
happen one day and it did.
And so when I had a chance
to invest in those companies,
I put hundreds of
thousands of dollars,
not millions but those
hundreds made millions,
made tens of
millions and so that's it.
Nothing crazy, nothing.
I didn't have any
crazy, crazy advantage.
There's a lot of people that
make $55,000
a year when they're 23.
The problem is they go to
Coachella and they want to
buy a watch and they want
to buy a BMW and I didn't.
So I ate shit for 13 years
and then I had a
moment and I struck.
And that moment changed
my financial outcome.
Little bit of a
curveball this morning.
Was going from Newark to
Chattanooga for our Chattanooga
holiday party but that was
canceled so now I'm flying to
Atlanta connecting and
then driving for
two hours to Chattanooga.
Sucks just 'cause I'm missing
out on three or four meetings
that I had to
have in Chattanooga.
Super inefficient
but curveballs happen.
That's how we do it.
So that's what's going on.
All good.
Had a good conversation
with my sister today.
Was good stuff.
Super proud of my
brother last night.
My brother, AJ, was honored
as man of the year at the
Crohn's and Colitis Foundation.
I'm very proud of him and
I love him very much and
I'm proud that he's come out and
talked about his disease and
bringing awareness to it and
hopefully find a cure
for a very tough disease.
Obviously for some of you,
you guys know that was the main
reason he left, not main, that's
the reason he left VaynerMedia
and so was an
emotional family day.
It's great,
I love him very much.
Now it's off to Atlanta.
I'm in Newark Airport just about
to board a flight originally to
Chattanooga, canceled.
Now I have to go to Atlanta
and then drive for
two hours so that's that.
And so that's what's going on.
Would love to answer
some of your questions,
would love to
bring you some value.
- [DRock] Do you
want to call people?
- I don't want to call people.
I'm more into
this live right now.
You want to do the call show?
Okay, I'll call one person.
What up, Italy?
- [Josh] Hello?
- Hello, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Josh] Oh my God,
I'm so happy to talk to you.
Oh my God.
Yo, I started my marketing--
- Hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on.
Romance a girl a
little bit here.
What's your name?
- [Josh] Josh Smith.
- Josh, how are you?
- [Josh] Great, man.
- Understand, Instagram
and Snapchat and Twitter,
these places, the best
ad product is Facebook.
And then Google Adwords.
And so, for a conversion based
thing but Facebook can convert
and build the brand but
Instagram content is fire and if
you know how to use hashtags.
Oh actually, you know what?
I have a concept.
I'm actually going to go off of
Instagram live right now and go
on the new Facebook,
Twitter live. Watch this.
I'm gonna give the most
tangible great piece of advice,
this is for you, brother, and
for everybody who's watching.
I'm gonna hang up
now on Instagram,
I'm going over to Twitter,
I'm doing a Twitter live and
I'm gonna go look at the
trending topics on Twitter and
I'm gonna pick one that's
trending and I'm gonna go live
which will then make that tweet
show up first and I'm gonna
build awareness to audiences
that don't know who I am.
Alright, I'll see
you guys on Twitter.
Going to Twitter,
it's GaryVee there
if you don't
follow me there.
If you don't have a
Twitter, sign up for it.
Don't be a dick.
This is literally
how my brain works.
Again, I keep
saying it over and over,
the reason DailyVee is gonna end
up being the biggest piece of
content, #AskGaryVee is better,
I get it for the people that are
students and
that's what you are.
But if you really, really
are wired in the way where you
understand
DailyVee being better,
it means you're more like me.
Plenty of people are more
successful than me
being students.
If you're a student you
like #AskGaryVee because
it's buh-buh, buh-buh.
But if you really understand and
watch what I do and how I do it
and observe me and watch me
and my environment and
that's why we edit so lightly.
You know, you're just trying to
put together something proper
but we don't edit because we
need you to see I'm in the
middle of something,
I think of something,
I don't put it off.
I don't ponder for
another day. The end.
Here we go.
Hit search, #ThursdayThoughts,
#ItConfusesMeWhen,
#ThursdayThoughts,
both are interesting to me.
I'm gonna go with
#ThursdayThoughts.
I'm gonna hit that.
Now it's added in there.
I'm gonna hit here,
I'm gonna go live.
It's telling me
now you can go live.
Okay, got it.
And I assume...
Twitter live Q&amp;A.
Now what we may learn
here is that by doing this
I'm getting more
awareness from people
that have never
heard of me before.
Let's see if that works.
Because again, on
Instagram, that's my community.
There's no
sharability in there
so there's no
discovery mechanism.
Whereas right now, here we go.
People are showing up.
Very nice.
Nice and fast,
440, 470, 489, 516.
You seeing this?
543, 589, 609.
Hey guys, hey guys,
hey guys, and we're back.
And we're back.
And we're here. And we're here.
Denver in the house.
From Instagram.
Everybody who's
Instagram say from Instagram.
Ugh, Tyler.
- [DRock] Call my
phone, call my phone.
- [Gary] Yeah, call him.
No, no, no, no, no.
- [DRock] Ah.
- It's gonna kill that too, ugh.
I tried to put it on
Do Not Disturb and
instead I put, ooh.
That would work, right?
Did that work?
You think if I Do Not Disturb
the calls won't come through?
- [DRock] I mean, yeah.
- [Gary] No, no, no.
The call.
- [DRock] Yeah, the
call won't come through.
- [Gary] That's what happened.
I didn't have that on.
That sucked.
Alright.
Alright, from Twitter Live.
By the way, let's go
on a retweet storm.
This retweeting is,
first of all,
so this is the thing that
I'm interested in which is if
I don't ask you for money or for
courses or all that bullshit but
instead what I'm really asking
for is your attention which
I'm so humbled by and then for
your word of mouth which then
brings more people in so that
they don't go and waste money on
bullshit internet marketing
fucking horse shit
mother fuckers then we can
really do something massive.
And I'm fascinated by that.
Look at all these retweets.
It's interesting.
Some retweeted, some are shared.
I think that's where the
Periscope difference is.
Look at this,
look at this.
Retweet, retweet,
retweet, retweet.
These guys are the best.
Alright, let me catch up
on my world a little bit.
I love you guys,
I'll be back on shortly.
My flight's delayed.
It's been a long day already.
See ya.
I've got a new
idea which I like.
Cody Gardener brought it up.
31, he just tweeted
I need a signed book.
I'll send you my signed
Joe Namath jersey
if you give me your signed book.
Done, trade completed.
(DRock laughs)
I'm now trading my signed
books for signed other things.
Things I like are
Randy "The Macho Man" Savage
and wrestling in general.
Knicks and Jets and anything
really weird and rare and cool.
("Hands" by Daywlk)